here on campaign check we're
scrutinizing the claims made on the
campaign trail and today we're starting
with the NHS traditionally seen as a
strong area for labour the Tories now
want to trump their rivals you might
have seen this video posted by Boris
Johnson online here's what he said about
health spending we're investing
massively in the NHS the biggest
investment for a generation biggest
investment in a generation now is that
actually right the Tories say they'll
spend about one hundred and forty eight
point five billion pounds on NHS England
by 2023 to twenty four that's thirty
three point nine billion more than in
2018 19 in cash terms that is the
biggest ever funding increase but here's
the thing that doesn't actually adjust
for inflation and if you do it's a very
different story an increase of 20 point
five billion pounds smaller than the
twenty four billion pounds real terms
increase under the last Labour
government so was Tony Blair a
generation ago not really so the claim
doesn't entirely stack up but it raises
another question how are the major
parties plans compared with what we've
seen in history and let's have a look
back to the early days of the NHS this
line here showing you UK wide health
spending so not just England like those
last numbers but no how even in real
terms the annual sum spent on the Health
Service has been climbing substantially
until the pace of growth tailed off
under austerity let's split that into
each different government since the war
so you can see how each party increased
health spending from Eden Macmillan to
wilson thatcher up by 3.3 percent
actually blair and brown up a whopping
six percent and just look that 1.3
percent increase since 2010 that's the
weakest annual increase in any
comparable period since the formation of
the NHS but what about the future and
the answer is under the conservative
stated plans you can see there's bit
here real spending would increase by
about 2.9 percent a year stronger than
during austerity but still the second
weakest growth rate in the history of
the NHS now it's worth being a little
cautious with this I'm basing it on NHS
spending also they might yet pledge more
health more social care spending in
their manifesto but it does put things
into perspective doesn't it what though
about labour and let's have a look at
their plans you can see the answer is a
steeper path of spending rising by about
four point three percent in real terms
again
this includes social care so it does
boost that number but 4.3% it's steep
but still slightly shy of the increases
under Blair and brown that's six percent
so the Tory plan not quite the biggest
plan spending increase in a generation
in fact it's not even the biggest in
this election